[Music]
in the midst of the occupied streets the
honking
the parties
and the security threats the canadian
military was trying to figure out what
it could or should do if the government
came calling asking for help this being
a very unstandard situation something
very exceptional
there's no doubt that
they were anticipating being asked
documents obtained by global news show
the military's top lawyer sent legal
advice to the chief of the defense staff
general wayne ayer within minutes of the
government invoking the emergencies act
titled canadian armed forces assistance
to law enforcement legal basis and
authorities the document is heavily
redacted page after page blanked out but
the military was also drawing a blank
scrambling to figure out what to do here
he had an unprecedented situation in
that the emergencies act had never been
invoked it's not uncommon for the
military to help out in domestic
emergencies like forest fires floods
even the pandemic but using the military
to help law enforcement is a touchy
subject but sources tell global news
rcmp commissioner brenda lucky wanted
military help not in the form of
soldiers in the streets alongside police
but she did want access to the help of
heavy towing capabilities the military
had so just because you called in the
armed forces it doesn't necessarily mean
you're necessarily looking to have
uniform members in the streets
helping police to do law enforcement
both law enforcement and military
sources say neither the chief of the
defense staff or the minister of
national defense wanted troops anywhere
near law enforcement
the document appears to give legal
advice along the same lines warning the
canadian armed forces have quote
flexible authority but it does not apply
to the provision of the canadian armed
forces assistance in relation to law
enforcement matters the document
references the military acting in
relation to the definition of quote
threats to the security of canada but
redact what those threats if any may
have been ironically perhaps the only
clear thing here is the confusion with
the military saying the emergencies act
doesn't make it clear how or if the
military is empowered to do something
all of this certainly has been a wake-up
call that the canadian armed forces are
operating in a new and unprecedented
environment farah
thanks mercedes mercedes stevenson is
reporting from ottawa tonight